[Música]
hoy voy a contarles de un antes y
después de mi vida
soy lakshmi y tal vez mi nombre o mi
vestido me acento llaman su atención
mi nombre fue dado por mi maestro y mi
vestido
es tibetano
lo uso como un homenaje al lugar donde
comenzó el tiempo más profundo de mi
vida donde descubrí el valor del tiempo
nací en inglaterra y a la edad de 10
años como es tradición de mi país fue
enviada a un internado y fue difícil en
el comienzo pero hermoso después porque
mis amigos en niños enviado de los cinco
continentes y para mí fue la primera vez
que sentí la amplitud del mundo después
estudié ciencia política sociología y
decidí por un palpitar hondo viajar a la
india
nací en el país del viven y la
puntualidad pero fue en la india donde
comencé de sentir el aroma del tiempo
como dijo el filósofo y un surjan sus
colores su diversidad su cultura antigua
me revelaron nuevas maneras de ver la
vida
viaje por meses pero fue en un pequeño
pueblo en la cima layers que se llama
dharamsala donde viven el dale lama los
refugiados tibetanos donde conocí a mi
maestro y él fue quien me enseñó las
tecnologías que voy a compartir hoy
quiero contarles una experiencia que me
hizo dedicar mi vida a este aprendizaje
así 25 años yo estaba en la y malaya
observando un amanecer
mientras que mier en los picos nevados
una baya extendía en frente
flores amarillas reflejaban el sol
y un arroyo corría a mi lado
estaba sentada al lado de mi maestro
intentando calmar mis pensamientos y
después de largos minutos me dijo
cuál es
su próximo pensamiento
cómo se siente su mente ahora
sintieron después de esas preguntas
quizá lo mismo que pasó a mí una pausa
cuando usualmente había un caudal de
pensamiento y este momento cree una gran
curiosidad de miel sobre la posibilidad
de entrenar la mente y experimentar la
paz
desde entonces he dedicado mi vida a
integrar estas experiencias no solo en
la montaña pero en mi hogar en el
trabajo y porque no en el tráfico
[Música]
mis tíos en algunas mentes quién es esa
mujer que quiere convencerme
tranquilos no quiero convencerlos de
nada simplemente quiero invitarlos a
experimentar esas tecnologías que tienen
valor potencial de innovar la forma como
estamos en la vida
estas tecnologías y usualmente asociamos
la palabra tecnología con el teléfono o
colin internet estas tecnologías
realmente tienen la capacidad de cambiar
la manera que interactuamos con la vida
la palabra tecnología significa la
integración del conocimiento
y ahora quiero invitarlos a conocer la
primera tecnología se llama
la atención
despierta
la atención despierta es un estado de
aventura es un estado de percibir pero
sin buscar
lo que nos pasa afuera y adentro de
nosotros
permitimos
no existe el futuro solamente existe el
fluir del presente
se puede experimentar en la vida cada
mañana practicó la atención despierta
camino con mi perro si va en el parque
san martín y cuando salgo de mi casa
comienzo a percibir los autos las
personas sin hogar
y cuando entro en el parque
despierto mis sentidos observo la luz
escuchó el canto de los pájaros de la
montaña al azul del cielo me hace
detenerme que me guía un silencio un
dulce silencio
lo sublime me conmueve y produce un
asombro tranquilo diría el filósofo kant
la tensión despierta
ahora quiero invitarlos a conocer la
concentración relajada la segunda
tecnología
[Música]
la idea en estas tecnologías vamos a
dirigir la mente en una sola dirección
usualmente en la vida permitimos que la
mente
salte de situación en situación
con la concentración relajada vamos a
entrenar la mente a irnos en una sola
dirección y vamos a permitir
y podemos incorporar un estado de calma
de precisión
podemos utilizar unas palabras para
ayudarnos como invito paz
podemos simplemente observar la
inspiración cuando inhalamos
y cuando exhalamos
y parece increíble parece una fantasía y
créeme
pero los últimos tres décadas los
científicos han hecho estudios y han han
comprobado que estas tecnologías tienen
la capacidad
de crear emociones positivas de subir el
sistema inmunológico
de crear más capacidad
y el trabajo
hay un estudio en particular de un
doctor richard davidson de la
universidad de marasmo descansen en 2012
él publicó un estudio donde con 19
universidades
las participantes practicaban estas
tecnologías y encontraron que estaban
completamente aliviados y su estrés
tenían más facilidad de estar felices
con otros
y en el mundo
gobiernos operaciones empresas colegios
universidades están incorporando estas
tecnologías en sillicon valley a más que
10 años las empresas están invitando a
sus empleados a hacer exactamente estas
tecnologías y en mi país la sistema
nacional de salud han incorporado esas
prácticas para las personas que están
recuperando su salud mental y emocional
ahora
que conocen la atención despierta y la
concentración relajada estarían
dispuestos de abrir las mentes
experimentar los conmigo
bien bien ok vamos a llevar la atención
por favor a su postura vamos a tener la
espalda recta para relajada vamos a
poner las plantas de los pies en el piso
y vamos a poner las manos sobre las
piernas
y ahora por favor si pueden observar la
habitación percibir pero sin buscar
percibir mirar llevando la atención de
otra manera
bien ahora por favor mira miami y pueden
respetar los sonidos
los sonidos
en el amor
xcel amos cierran por favor los párpados
y van a llevar la atención a su cuerpo
a las sensaciones de su cuerpo
[Música]
y van a repetir en la mente estoy atento
estoy atento
la atención despierta
y llevar la tensión
la sinfonía de la vida
ahora vamos a entrar a la concentración
relajada
muy lentamente vas a poner una mano
sobre tu estómago y vamos a usar la
respiración como enfoque para la
concentración relajada cuando en a la
invitas el aire llegará a su estómago
[Música]
xcel ando dejando y los estreses
y vamos a pensar invito paz
[Música]
en mi tropa
invito paz en el amor
xcel amos
en el oriente dice que la mente es como
el mar siempre en la superficie ola sin
ruido pero la profundidad habita paz
muy lentamente puedes bajar tu mano
inhalamos y lentamente abriendo los
párpados
manteniendo el contacto con ese estado
de la atención despierta y la
concentración relajada
estas tecnologías pueden ayudarnos
de apreciar y vivir en el presente
pueden ayudarnos de tener el valor del
tiempo
para vivir en un deleite profundo
los invito a practicar esas tecnologías
y llevar ese paz al otro y al mundo
los invito y les pregunto
cómo se sienten
sus mentes ahora
muchas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]